[Music]
if you saw the documentary the social
dilemma on netflix then you heard a lot
from tristan harris
he used to work in big tech and now he's
on a crusade to tell us all about the
dangers of social media and what we can
do to protect ourselves
this
is a bit of optimism
hey tristan thanks for joining me
you've already had an
incredibly intense year
can we start with your experience with
the california wildfires yeah i had been
based in san francisco and then when the
pandemic hit i actually moved into my
family home that i grew up in up in
santa rosa which is in sonoma county
and two weeks after the social dilemma
came out a huge wildfire came through
calistoga and sonoma county and
basically overnight incinerated
everything that uh i i know and grew up
with and we had to evacuate we had 30
minutes to to leave
it's crazy to go through something like
that you know um waking up the next day
and get a text message from your
neighbor saying
it's gone two other houses in the
neighborhood
also burned many were spared we were one
of the unlucky ones but
as is true in existentialism
the meaningfulness of something is what
happens afterwards and the meaning you
continue to make and so
i think i'm trying to turn it into the
sweetest thing that's ever happened by
rebuilding a better life and living
situation afterwards so it's been a
crazy year did you have a chance to
mourn
what about your family i mean this was
the house you grew up in so this was um
the house that i grew up in with my
mother and actually strange fact the
house burned down exactly two years
after her passing wow which is it's this
very strange twist of fate i don't think
i really mourned until november after
getting through a huge amount of the
press and media tour and i think there
was a big big release of kind of just
recognizing what had happened and uh
yeah it's been it's been a crazy journey
well talking about the social dilemma
you know that was one of those
shows on netflix that had everybody
talking
and really for the first time made
people realize the danger and feel fear
for the way that
social media is in our lives and more
importantly the way the companies
manipulate our lives how did you get on
that journey in the first place how did
you become the spokesperson waving the
flag at all of us look here look here
what like how did that journey begin for
you i think it's easy to look at a film
like the social dilemma or my background
and assume that
you know i'm kind of this uh luddite
anti-tech critic or something like that
and that we should go back to the stone
age or um that i'm an anti-technology
person i actually went to stanford
studied computer science was classmates
with the founders of instagram
was part of a group with one of the
founders kevin systrom who's the was the
ceo of instagram and we were part of a
social impact-oriented group about how
could we use computer science to make
the most positive social impact in the
world and so that was the
upbringing that i had at stanford and
you worked in big tech yeah yeah i
worked at apple when i was 18 years old
as an intern i worked at jimmy wales
wikipedia spin-off called wikia and then
i started my own technology company and
raised venture capital and went through
that whole
you know round so i really saw the
pressures that are on entrepreneurs you
know when you when you raise venture
capital you have to grow a certain way
there's a pressure to grow to x million
users as fast as possible and if you
don't get that flywheel turning you know
you know your thing is debt you can't
raise more money so
in my case our company that i that i'd
started called apt sure
it's actually you know it's an important
story because it sets up the fallacy
that i think is at the root of
everything the social dilemma is is
calling out so back in 2007 i was at
stanford a young naive 21 22 year old
kid with my friends thinking hey we
could make the world a better place if
we could get people to care about things
that they didn't know about and my naive
thinking when i was 21 years old
with our friends brainstorming this was
what if when you're in the internet and
there's you know someone's talking about
something like you know a specific food
shortage in ethiopia in a certain region
you know you read that over that you've
never been to ethiopia you don't even
know the names of the cultural tribes
there or the history how could you
expect someone to care about it so
apture was this service that we worked
with web publishers like the economist
like washington post originally was the
publisher could actually link up a
phrase like this is the region of
ethiopia that has the food shortage and
you'd hover over it and boom you'd see
an immediate video you were transported
there and you saw the people rummaging
around in some refugee camp and they
didn't have food and it was like say
some video from the bbc and then it had
right there next to it a map of exactly
where that was and maybe you could link
a map of where the reader was from or
something like that and show you you
know you could associate these things
and and make it visible right there on
the washington post or right there on
the economist or the bbc without leaving
the page so at the risk of leading the
witness here because i think
i know where we're going
what was so naive about that
if we're jumping to the punch line of
what the core thing that you know after
it took me by the way six and a half
years to learn this lesson yeah which is
really not learning a lesson but
honestly getting out of denial um as the
ceo of the and founder of the company
um you're so good at telling yourself
the story we're getting people to care
about things we're getting people to
care about things you can't see through
your own story which by the way we're
going to get to when we talk about the
silicon valley leaders that are telling
themselves stories about what their
products are doing right but the core
point you're bringing up was
what did the economist or the washington
post care about when we did that deal
with them to put this on their website
and what really mattered to them simon
was
are you increasing the amount of time on
my website are you increasing engagement
do you get five more page views for
every page view someone clicks on do you
get more ad revenue and if we didn't
keep engagement high
they would take our product off their
website so my business was existential
right to whether or not we were
delivering on the engagement proposition
and you know you think about facebook
and twitter and youtube and you say what
are those services doing well if i want
to if i'm running youtube i can tell
myself a story we're helping people
learn about things we're helping people
watch those videos that pump you up and
get motivated with that pounding music
and you wake up in the morning we're
helping people look at music videos and
artists and we're helping creators you
know have new businesses there's all
these young people who can create a
whole new 15 000 a month you know
businesses off of reviewing products and
we're enabling new economies you can
tell all those stories
but at the end of the day
what is youtube's business model
it's got to drive more time on site
from more users and getting people to
share more of those videos to more
people
every single month and their stock price
is directly connected to those set of
facts can you sum up what you believe
the danger of social media is
when
you have
three or four technology companies that
are kind of the brain implant for human
civilization meaning they
think about you being at home for the
last year and you're staring outside
your window as i'm doing right now
do i know what's happening in that world
by through my own eyeballs or do i have
to reference my brain implant of social
media to say
what's going on in oregon right now is
it a war zone is there a heat wave
happening in the northwest that's all
dictated by social media so the first
thing to recognize is that social media
has become
the reality constructing infrastructure
for our minds that by itself is not a
problem but it's important let's say
that again social media constructs our
reality for us
correct it is not looking out a window
it is looking at their screen
their screen their window of reality so
are my friends all happy and basically
on beaches in tulum you know according
to instagram that's the reality of my
friends lives is everyone angry all the
time or is twitter basically casting
this huge net for everything everyone is
angry about over the last week and then
saying in case you missed it in the last
72 hours here's a list of outrage
so these things have basically sorted
for a very particular set of things that
are good for them which is getting
attention
in the case of instagram
things that inspire anorexia are really
good for teen girls and getting their
attention in the case of instagram for
young boys basically soft porn rabbit
holes of just infinite photos of hot
girls are what keeps those young boys
attention in the case of youtube the
conspiracy theories and kind of rabbit
holding on holocaust denial and flat
earth conspiracy videos were really good
at getting attention in the case of
facebook extreme groups recommended to
people were really good at getting
people's attention and that radicalized
the world in the case of facebook and
twitter and tick tock personalizing
people's news feeds is better at getting
attention than not personalizing their
news feeds which means that affirmation
rather than information is what
dominates that reality constructing
infrastructure we have been deranged as
a society inadvertently not not
intentionally but by these these brain
implants which are these three or four
tech companies that have dominated
especially in a coveted world the way
that we see the world and i think most
people can relate to they have friends
or family members that feel like they
can't talk to anymore because they have
some other different set of views than
them
and we've all been kind of radicalized
in some more extreme direction we don't
know it because we only see well the
other side looks like they're really
crazy while they say the same thing
about ours you know increasing what
we're seeing you know there's a study
that came out in the wall street uh
journal it was basically cited in a
facebook internal document that 64
of the extremist groups are talking like
the white nationalist groups that the
you know the craziest most intense
militant groups on facebook were
actually driven by facebook's own
recommendation system wow and so here's
an example my probably grenade diresta
written about this exclusively she
became a new mom
and she joined a organic baby food moms
group so it's like moms who want to make
their own baby food okay so it sounds
great this is by the way back in like 20
maybe 16 17. what do you think was the
top recommended group for
new moms who were in this organic baby
food group i shudder to think you shut
her to think well it's obviously been
politicized now but um this was
basically moms against vaccines and what
she found in her research is once you
join one of those groups
the the the vaccine groups yeah then it
said hey by the way do you want q anon
or hey by the way do you want flat earth
or chemtrails
and it would show people all of these
other groups now regardless of the truth
statements of some of the contents of
some of those other topics
just noticing this is how the machine
worked for for about 10 years right so
so now you rewind the clock and you say
okay our society has gone insane yeah
and you realize that we've got this
brain implant stuck in our society and
you rewind the clock and say we've been
through 10 years of this unregulated
derangement process from social media
recommending certain things and not
others and selecting for the things that
would most
hijack our limbic system what's going
through my mind as you're talking about
this is
it's a little bit like oppenheimer and
the bomb
right
nobel and tnt as well same thing at the
time alfred nobel was developing you
know tnt he believed he was going to
create the most powerful weapon ever so
that he could bring about peace in the
world
that didn't happen he regretted his work
ironically he is then the architect and
author of the nobel peace prize
oppenheimer is working on the nuclear
bomb the manhattan project thinking that
he can develop this weapon it'll bring
peace in the world because it'll be more
powerful than anything else and turns
out he was thrown off the project as
soon as he starts quoting the bhagavad
gita and i think what ends up happening
with extremely powerful things like
nuclear bombs or social media is that
though they may have been founded with
idealistic and positive intentions
there's always balance
social media does a lot of good and it
also does a lot of evil it's balanced
but if it did less good it would do less
evil
and so the question i have is is the
whole thing to restrain it in and one
cannot help but look at authoritarian
regimes whether it's russia
or the more restrictive application of
social media in china
that they
just don't have
the troubles that we seem to have
with an open
access social media in other words they
don't have the benefits but they also
don't have
the the destruction or am i completely
missing something here the world is
trending towards these
two different attractors right now that
if you sort of take your hand off the
steering wheel you know we're heading
into climate change we're heading into
these extreme volatile periods of
history and the two ways of relating to
that are governments trending towards
authoritarianism and oppression which is
the orwellian world which is like let's
just have one big master state that just
changes the climate timelines that just
you know locks up human behavior that
coerces people and is against freedom
that's one dystopia we don't want to
head towards but also has certain
benefits in the ways that it will maybe
deal with climate change because it can
just top down exert that that governance
structure
the other attractor is chaos which is
basically just let's maximize the sort
of freedom which is basically maximizing
polarization disagreement chaos this is
all getting very
philosophical
right and it's
the trouble i have with this whole
discussion
is that it's all very lofty
it's also
abdicates any kind of personal
responsibility
big tech needs to do this government
needs to do other people need to do this
and i disagree with the idea that it's
either freedom or chaos the reality is
is all of these organizations all of our
government entities all policy starts
with an individual if we go in into
facebook where are the employees
we've seen it happen we've seen
employees exert tremendous pressure on a
company like where is the moral outrage
where is the ethical standard
all of this is solved with personal
accountability because one of the things
we neglected about looking out the
window is who's in your house
how are you treating the people in your
house forget about what's out the window
that's where i think the solution lies
it's not chaos or freedom
it's me to you it's how i treat my
friends and how i think about myself in
in this system
rather than a victim somebody who can do
something at a very small scale which
turns out lots of people working at
small scale adds up to big scale
what i hear you saying is the the third
attractor beyond oppression or chaos is
responsibility
yeah like a parent who restricts their
kid on
facebook a couple who one says the other
honey
let's put them away and leave our phones
at home
and go out for a walk
do a jigsaw puzzle read a book watch a
movie you know whatever it is
you and i have both been victim to it
i'm victim to it which is you're with a
friend one of you picks up the phone the
other one feels stupid so the other one
picks up the phone and before you know
it you've both gone down a rabbit hole
and 20 minutes later one looks up and
goes we should probably stop shouldn't
we i literally have probably more
encyclopedic knowledge on the various
persuasive mechanisms and manipulation
techniques and
i don't know 99 of people on the planet
and i literally get influenced and
sucked into these things all the time
because the point is you're we are all
trapped in that meat and i want to say
one thing which is to just acknowledge
asymmetries of power so
we we can understand when we're being
victimized or being manipulated without
identifying as a victim and staying in
that place i'll give you the example of
a teenager who sees social dilemma or
listens to this you and i right now and
says you know what today's the day
i'm actually going to right after
listening to this turn off my
notifications from all these damn things
i'm going to uninstall these five apps
from my phone
and i'm going to make a commitment about
what things in my embodied life in the
real world i'm going to choose to do
for a teenager i want to go into this
teenager example
all of their friends are still all the
sexual opportunities all the homework
gossip all the gossip about who's doing
what to whom
that is all
still happening in the instagram world
in the tik-tok world in the snapchat
world
and one of the diabolical aspects of the
asymmetry of power here the
victimization
is that social media companies actually
by design prey on social exclusion that
if you leave by yourself it's not an
individual choice because you're
actually losing access to what it means
to be
growing up within that social cohort of
your other friends
and they know this and they manipulate
it and so just to extend i don't
disagree with the taking responsibility
i would just say we have to do it as a
group you know we have to do it as a
society because if a whole school would
you do it
how do you make something you can't make
a society do something that's not how
societies work
i think we're missing something here
which is the fact that we are we're not
just a society of numbers and random
individuals
nor are we a society of individuals who
just live a life in our own silos
but we are both individuals and members
of groups at all times and what makes us
feel worth is not
necessarily what we feel about ourselves
but what others feel about us
and simply telling someone do this for
yourself so that you feel better is not
a good motivator just like it's not a
good motivator say go to the gym so
you'll feel better about yourself
because as i've learned
i'm totally fine disappointing myself
like sitting in bed and not going to the
gym and not working out i'm fine
but
if i have someone that i'm going to work
out with i do not want to let them down
and that's different and i think the
thing we're missing is when you go down
these rabbit holes you are making your
friends feel excluded you're making your
friends feel lonely and if you want your
friends to feel loved if you want the
people you love to feel loved
then put it away or turn it off
and i think we've forgotten the service
element of this this whole journey began
of selfishness how can i make more money
using this thing
how am i going to make people watch and
then the people who go down the rabbit
holes all very selfishly driven
and i think the part that's missing here
is service what makes you optimistic
this is i mean like this the podcast is
a bit of optimism and you know a lot of
this is very dark
and social dilemma
is kind of dark you know
i mean what makes you feel that all of
this work is not simply idealism and
trying to do the right thing but
actually is working
what's going in the right direction that
makes us feel like this is we should
continue fighting this because there
actually is progress
if you told me back in 2013
that we'd have chris hughes the facebook
co-founder saying it's time to break up
facebook that we'd have internal
employees writing letters and basically
joining whistleblowing programs to
saying we have to change things from the
inside that you'd have 130 million
people watch the social dilemma that you
would have um governments from the eu to
new zealand to canada to the us that are
actively working on dealing with these
issues
the structure of this machine
has been very hard to penetrate i don't
want to give people some false hopes
about that
but the pace of the conditions of people
turning around in their world views on
all of this stuff whether it's actually
frankly on climate or on social media i
think that the pace of that has
increased dramatically and and you have
to use that to extrapolate forward
saying just like five years ago eight
years ago i would have never been able i
would have wouldn't believe you that the
things that are happening now that are
positive would have ever happened i have
to sort of anchor right now and say
given the pace of those things that
there's going to be future things that i
would never have believed you that are
going to have to happen you've made some
personal sacrifices to do this i mean
some of the stuff that you designed back
as an 18 year old working at apple is
still in a shipped macintosh to this day
you worked at google you had big jobs
you had the startups you made the money
you could have been one of the
billionaires
and yet you you walked away from that
life to do something that you thought
was on a moral and ethical higher ground
at great personal sacrifice you were not
the friend of the big companies with
huge amounts of money and tons and tons
of lawyers
what makes it all worth it
if the pace of change is slow even
though there is some change
you know
you could
you could just go write some nice
technology and
make an okay living and
your work will be good work why should
you keep doing it the very end of the
social dilemma there's a quote from me
where it says
it seems crazy to think that
we have to change the whole thing the
whole system the way that it's working
but when you see where it's going
you realize that we don't have any other
choice and then the director asked me do
you think we're ever going to get there
and my answer is we have to
thanks justin i i appreciate you taking
the time
this is a hard subject and when i
invited you on like i know what the
podcast is called and i was like okay
this is i know what we're gonna talk
about
but given the world that we're in i
think it's important to talk about it
the summary
is is that technology will not solve the
technology problem or technology will
not solve a human problem we have to
stop using technology to solve human
problems give people a hug say i love
you say do you want to go for a coffee
with me go for a walk that's what solves
all of this stuff all of it
all of it not an app not a social media
anything not a regulation although we
need all those things because it's run
amok
to truly get back to being human we
actually have to be human
couldn't agree more
tristan thanks so much for joining me
please keep fighting the good fight
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself
take care of each other